welcome to this video and as Sarah's
endless indeed source difficult probably
completely mispronouncing both names
here again trying a somewhat uncommon
line you end up in the room g6 line it's
not so bad one of the better sight lines
so I think Kiki and go d 6 i'm not
mistaken probably castling it also
around
Black's idea is to play something like
d6 night 85 and c5 for some beano nice
tile position hmm just like that okay
I'd like to go at 5am the right moment
maybe also gt5 96 it's not so easy for
him to develop the Queen side with this
Bishop pointing added ok this is super
ambitious but maybe I get stuff like
that played against me all the time and
those kind of super ambitious moves that
should work and somehow it sometimes to
work ok so cut this in maybe night here
now 495 odd is f5 a move or is this is
really far too crazy and the light
squares look sick after it ok anyway
let's go here
ok
Wow night to h5 in 1934 very interesting
I have fleets likely played that very
well somehow
didn't expect that okay at least there's
no use in thinking that much I have to
check that night cannot accept it on in
five okay didn't expect Bishop f4 really
i thought i'm going to try to somehow
keep my night out is this so bad that
doesn't look too bad
no yeah I'm here really ok I think he's
helping me here to W on the e-file
that's nice maybe I get in cookie to
Bishop g4 stuff no we actually played
Bishop deform earlier ok so I have to
drop this back and then go Bishop g4
I can do this and then go look III right
threatening look III and it's not a
threat actually he's got Quincy form
then it's it's kind of possible but not
I mean age five is very cheeky
earth-threatening rookie three but it's
a threat so why not maybe it's not
paying attention
takes a six rupee three I think wins the
house or at least enough let's say okay
here it's again kind of possible where's
he going takes rook takes Queen fo
Bishop b5 and maybe this position isn't
so clear that that's possible because of
that that a polite resides just resins
stockfish is only giving me zero point
six so I'm am that isn't that isn't
clear at all it was probably you
probably overlooked that somehow yeah
the thing is this is really cheeky
business because his has this great this
great porn and he can just do this so it
was a complete bluffy on my part I mean
unwillingly how do you thought it would
work but this is a good move cos yep it
just gets out of this and here widest
winning I have no checks or a check or
whatever and this this point is winning
the game so that wasn't very solidly
played maybe I should have started with
Bishop b5 that might save a temple in
the long run here maybe before and this
this I could have played this here but I
what I saw it was I saw this check is
the check I saw this but it didn't feel
so great to me but now looking at it
it's not bad it's really not bad at all
he cannot take f4 and well it's a couple
of points and the noise pollution hmm
yeah so it was possible and this move
that I call cheeky is just just bad yeah
but okay I think he wasn't he was a bit
too too shocked hear me even though this
isn't clear ma'am and pawn Teague's in
the Bishop c4 as I said the engine just
gives black a slight advantage which is
a difficult assessment of course as the
position is super sharp here would
actually believe that black should be
better by some kind of I mean should be
something
no yeah I think black is somewhat better
here 0.4 according to stalkerish it is
in a practical game I think black is
better the deep on is kind of controlled
at the moment and groups who condemned
Queen active well it's not easy at all
okay thanks for watching